hello there watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time then to see what is making the
headlines with the editor of the
sheffield star nancy fielder and the
conservative commentator tim montgomery
very good to see both of you
as ever though we turn our attention to
the front pages let's start with the
financial times which leads on joe biden
marking the anniversary of the storming
of the capitol building saying the
president fears for the state of
american democracy
prisoner cell jock h is the headline for
tomorrow's metro referring to the tennis
player caught up in immigration
detention on the australian border the
guardian has an exclusive on
conservative peer michelle moan and
allegations which she denies surrounding
contracts for ppe
higher taxes for 1 million people
earning more than 50 000 pounds a year
that's the top story for the telegraph
rising fuel bills and prices to hit over
65s the hardest the squeeze splashed on
the front page of the express
the daily mirror reports that prince
andrew has allegedly had to sell his 17
million pound skiing retreat as he
prepares to pay legal bills
fears over space travelers eyesight
should have gone to spock savers that's
the front of the daily style which has
to be said is on a bit of a roll
uh so let's get the thoughts then of
nancy field and tim montgomery the first
time i can remember for a while where
every single paper has a different
headline that they've chosen um so tim
what was your choice you picked up on
the comments of joe biden one year on
from the capitol riots
yes it's um
of course a year ago
when those momentous events really
shocked uh all of us and obviously five
people did die
but it could have been so much worse we
could have seen some of the leading
politicians in america killed
as well and so i think it's absolutely
right that we regard this uh occasion uh
with uh gravity
and
hope that finally um we will see some
coming together of the american
political system but i'm afraid what
we're seeing is height and rhetoric not
just from the republicans but from the
democrats as well and people trying to
use this occasion now as an opportunity
to to advance their own politics rather
than to try and heal and bring a very
divided country back together
well a prayer vigil underway on the
capitol steps today with the uh the
speaker um
you know speaking right now but this is
the uh the earlier pictures of
those members of congress who are
walking down those steps uh candles in
hand to mark that moment which was
really nancy seen by many as an assault
on democracy in america and remains the
case that they they feel
in in some respects the reflections of
it are still damaging
yes i mean it was intended as an assault
on democracy that's absolutely what they
wanted to do and that is what they
achieved and as tim said this could have
been so much worse they took over didn't
they as millions of people across the
world watched absolutely staggered that
america looked like it completely lost
control and temporarily in the heart of
the political center control had been
lost so it's absolutely right that they
come together that they remember and
actually that work is done so that this
can't be allowed to happen again and
there's a lot of talk around our people
playing politics here but this is
politics the whole debate was around
that and it was about an election that
was lost or stolen as we all remember
all too well so to say people playing
politics today well we need to remember
but actually there is a lot of a debate
still going on across america and it
seems almost as divided now as it was
then yes and another turbulent year
ahead as well tim the senate the house
the midterms it's looking fragile for
for joe biden and the democrats too with
many choices being made by republicans
still with the background of mr mr trump
it's i mean it's still an extraordinary
picture in the states in terms of
politics there
yes um anyone who writes donald trump
off
should uh be very cautious i think i
think a year ago
many of us thought that his support for
the kind of activity
that led to
what we saw in capitol hill would
finally be the end of his political
career but most opinion polls suggest
that he's still the leading candidate
for republican
voters and the danger i think is that
joe biden who came
to the
white house promising to unify america
is now a very unpopular president ahead
of those midterms that you mention and
so what he's now trying to do is just
get his core vote uh to turn out and
that is done he thinks by being
increasingly negative about trump and
the republicans and firing up core
democratic voters but in terms of the
healing of america's sad political
situation we're not going to get it from
joe biden just as we didn't get it from
donald trump
nancy let's move on shall we to the
metro rather a clever um headline for
them prisoner cell jock h although some
people who are not as old as i am but
remember the tv show that it's referring
to but i mean this is this is not going
away protests in melbourne protests in
belgrade you know extraordinary words
from the serbian prime minister not to
mention jokovich's parents he's stuck
there you know what happens now
this is my favorite front page of a long
time i didn't realize it made me old but
maybe it does but i mean what a
fantastic play on words that is and
actually if you're not a massive tennis
fan and if you're not a massive fan of
djokovic maybe this is something that
actually is a little bit laughable so if
you look at where the world is how this
panda how this pandemic is going and
impacting and destroying so many lives
and here we have international front
pages looking at a millionaire an
incredibly good sportsman but a
millionaire who has chosen not to do
what he needed to do
to play to defend to get that 10th title
to get more adoration and more money so
i mean there is a bit of a
laughter in this i think but yeah there
is absolute outrage in his home country
there are fans outside the hotel where
they think he is and apparently the
awful conditions are just too terrible
to bear but as we know there are lots of
people who've had to travel to australia
to say farewell to people who are dying
who've gone in far worse circumstances
and i have to say well i'm not a great
tennis fan but my sympathy here is rock
bottom who was i mean let's talk about
the care workers who've lost their jobs
because they couldn't work because they
weren't vaccinated who were on the red
line anyway and here we are worrying
about this millionaire maybe maybe i've
got it wrong maybe i just don't enjoy
tennis enough when that that's it it's
it's a talking point certainly isn't it
the metro does point out that he's
refused to say if he's been jabbed but
the fact that officials ruled his plea
for medical exemption was insufficient
one presumes he has not been uh it has
to has to be said but australia has some
of the strictest conditions in the world
or has done over the last nearly two
years tim
is it right though that being vaccinated
or unvaccinated should be so divisive
oh goodness knows but i think it's a
little bit related to our last story
in a way we seem to be incapable whether
it's senior politicians or pundits to be
able to react to any story in a sort of
a moderate way you know we have the
serbian political leadership accusing
australia of uh
favoring other tennis players because
their guy isn't being allowed into
australia australia of course has an
election coming up so is the australian
government playing a tough approach to
immigration to win the election
no one seems to be able to deal with
anything in a calm way at the moment the
divisions that we see in america seem to
be seeping into political discourse
generally i think a lot of it is to do
with social media i think partly if i
dare say it's the 24 7 news cycle that
we have but just the lack of any sort of
generosity of spirit towards
each other a lack of
grown-up political debate is is
despairing really yeah and to be fair
it's uh is plan b enough or not is part
of this debate is it you know it all it
all rolls in isn't it this sort of
diverse opinion we hear um but the metro
picking up uh in relation to the jokovic
story and not um this mumbo-jumbo idea
about anti-vax nonsense that boris
johnson spelt out today if if if you put
all your policy is about vaccination you
really do need to get as many people
vaccinated and boosted as possible nancy
yeah you do and you do need these big
sports styles
and these celebrities and the people who
different generations hold in high
esteem to be on board with that i mean
they are incredibly powerful it doesn't
matter whether you like that or not that
is the truth and actually yes the
politicians right across the world if
the message is vaccination and it should
be and it is because that is a way to
save lives and that is the way to make
sure the health services aren't so
overwhelming they can't cope then they
need everybody on board so yeah today
the prime minister said it was all
mumbo-jumbo i mean i i'm fighting my
tongue as to the amount of mumbo jumbo
phrases that we've had from him himself
but actually on this one i do agree
there is so much
utter rubbish that has been spread
around and that we know not to be true
about vaccines and it's scaring people
and it is stopping people from taking a
vaccine that could save their life
but i think that works both ways if i
could just briefly look i support
vaccination and vaccines are essential
way of keeping everyone safe but people
who support faxes need to be careful
about what they say as well i think
there's been exaggeration for example
that if you are vaccinated then you know
you don't transmit we now learn that's
absolutely not the case and actually by
overselling the case for vaccines we
actually encourage those people who
don't want vaccines to think that
actually there is something that they're
generally uh being hidden from them so
we all need to be responsible in how we
talk about vaccines not just
those who disagree with us yes the
medical advisors do clarify that don't
they that if you have been vaccinated
you are less likely to get it and
therefore less likely to transmit and
boris johnson today is suggesting that
when you look at what's happening to
patients coming into hospital a large
number of them perhaps 30 to 40 percent
of them haven't actually been vaccinated
at all and that's increasingly true of
people who go into icu
and given such large proportion of the
nation has been vaccinated then clearly
that is disproportionate uh but the
question i was going to ask you tim in
fact was we're at the point now can
hospitals cope
and you know clearly the move is now
towards the northwest in terms of the
epicenter of this epidemic um and
whether the case is there are still
rising which is what the figures seem to
show so you know lots of data is still
to emerge in the coming days
yeah i think we seem to be getting to
the position where
the risk to the nhs isn't from a large
number of patients um omicom has
affected many people but not in the
serious way that delta
did but we have got a large number of
nhs staff already exhausted after a very
punishing couple of years having to
self-isolate so i welcome very much the
government's efforts to measures to
reduce the period that you have to
self-isolate most people don't really
have any serious infection when they're
getting this virus and i think we need
our economy we need our public services
operating so i think the balance that
the government is striking is about
right at the moment but yes the nhs um
does look like it's going to be okay but
yeah we need to be vigilant i'm just
going to squeeze in can i just
go on okay go
so a friend of mine's mom fell over on
tuesday morning in the northeast broke
her hip waited for 12 hours at home in
agony for an ambulance and then waited
for 36 hours on a trolley in a hospital
she still hasn't had that operation even
if you put kobe to one side and how many
people have it the nhs is not coping
it's absolute nonsense it's on its knees
as it is every winter and the pandemic
is making it worse
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the editor of
the sheffield star nancy fielder and the
conservative commentator tim montgomery
welcome back both of you so let's go to
the daily telegraph nancy uh the prime
minister in his wallpaper for access row
over a donor's plan for a great
exhibition do explain
absolutely so these are the texts that
our prime minister who you might have
thought might be on top of where the
money comes from at least somebody in
his team might be
forgot about these whatsapp messages
forgot to reveal them in the big
scandals it's been going on for months
now
about who paid for the flat in the end
he paid for it to be refurbished but it
already been funded
by somebody else who happens to give
lots of money to the conservative party
and these whatsapp messages also
discussed a great exhibition which never
actually happened i believe but it's a
great example of kind of this was not a
canadian person when it is not connected
to anything it this is an example of
kind of do you want to do this and don't
forget i won't forget about this it's
sort of rubbing each other's back it
seems to me and the prime minister
insists he's done nothing wrong
but frankly i think most people see it
for what it is and it's interesting
because i don't think this really cut
through until the wine and cheese and
everybody else is in lockdown and we're
having non-parties in downing street but
i think because that one has such an
impact on voters i think the more and
more of these things that we get and i
have no doubt there will be more similar
scandals coming through i think it just
kind of adds to the pile and i'd be
amazed if we have the same prime
minister when the next election comes
around yes i mean tim this was all right
when boris was teflon politician um he
clearly is not now and quite frankly you
know you're doing a flat a flat in an
unstable job with which is a which is a
short let effectively so what what was
the point of all this expenditure apart
from apart from this idea that you're
not supposed to know where the money
comes from in case you have favor and
here it looks like in these messages
favor is being looked into
look to be fair there is there is a i
think a 30 000 pound allowance for every
new prime minister uh you know different
prime ministers have different family
arrangements they have to live above the
shop in downing street and so i can
understand why some work might have
needed to be done but yes some it seemed
to be much more ambitious
than perhaps was necessary
the prime minister probably thought he
had got away with it as you sort of
suggested but i think where the british
people are they will forgive one or two
transgressions they know we all make
mistakes in in life but the problem the
prime minister has now is that there
have been far too many of these uh
lapses i think
because of his chaotic personal
management rather than any sort of
fundamentally unethical behavior but he
really can't afford further missteps
like this or i'm afraid his reputation
for
probity will really be lost and i think
conservative mps will be watching him
very carefully and saying this must be
the last occasional near the last
occasion when you mess up like this
prime minister